so
given the insight so far let's now go
and design
the most powerful graph neural network
so
let's go and design the most expressive
graph neural network and
let's develop the theory that will allow
us to do that
so the key observation so far is that
the expressive power of a graph neural
network
can be characterized by the expressive
power
of the neighborhood aggregation function
they use because the more expressive the
neighborhood aggregation
leads to a more expressive graph neural
network
and we saw that if the neighborhood
aggregation is injective
this leads to the most expressive gnn
neighborhood aggregation being injective
it means that whatever is the
number and features of the of the
children
you you map every different combination
into a different output so no
information get
gets lost so let's do the following next
let's theoretically analyze the
expressive power
of different uh aggregation functions
so the way you think of neighborhood
aggregation
basically taking the information from
the children and aggregating is
that neighborhood aggregation can be
obstructed as a
function over a multiset a multi-set is
simply a set
with repeated elements right so if you
say
i'm a note here and i aggregated from
two neighbors for
two children this is the same as saying
i have a set of children
uh two yellow guys and i need to
aggregate information
from them right and of course in a multi
set
um notes can have different colors node
can have different features
so you know you could say aha i have a i
have two children
one with yellow attribute and the other
one with blue attribute
versus some other node has um three
children
two of them with yellow attribute or
yellow feature
and one uh with the blue feature and
when we aggregate
this information we want the the new
message the aggregated information
not to be lost somehow we wanna the uh
to in this aggregation in this
compression step
basically to retain all the information
we know about the children right so here
we wanna say
two yellow and the blue and here we
wanna say one yellow
and one blue so that these two multisets
still remain uh distinguishable as
as we are aggregating them uh to their
parent
so that then we aggregate this parent
further to the super parent
uh no information uh gets lost
so let's look at uh the neighborhood
information
aggregation functions used by the two
models that we have discussed so far in
the class first we'll talk about
gcn which uses mean pooling it uses
element-wise mean pulling over
neighborhood node features
and then let's talk about the max
pooling variant of graph's edge
that uses element-wise maximum pulling
over
neighboring node features and let's see
what is the expressive power of min
and what is the expressive power of max
pulling
so let's first talk about gcn
so the mean pulling when you average the
messages coming from the
from the children uh if we take the
element-wise mean
then in a gcn it's followed by a linear
function
and a value activation function um
and what is uh what is the observation
the observation function is that gcn's
aggregation function
cannot distinct distinguish multi
different multisets
with the same kind of proportion of
colors right so for example
um this is a failure case when you
average together messages
it doesn't doesn't matter whether you
average one yellow and one blue message
or whether you average two yellow and
two blue messages at the end
the average is the same right and this
is the failure case
of the average it it will combine
these two multisets it will aggregate
them into the same
uh into the same message so it means it
will lose information
in the case that here are um one and one
and here is
two and two because the ratio is the
same so
let me be a bit more precise and give
you a proper example
let's for simplicity assume that note
colors
are represented as one hot encodings
right so now every node
every node has a feature vector that
simply encodes what color
is the color of the node right that is
its feature vector
and this is just kind of a a way to
illustrate
uh this concept and what happens when we
do
uh aggregation right so for example
when you do a average of uh two vectors
uh one zero and zero ones you you get
uh half and half so that's your
aggregated message now of these two uh
feature vectors
uh in this case when you have a multiset
again of two yellow and two blue
here are the corresponding feature
representations if i take the
the element-wise average of these
four vectors i also get half-half
so it means that even if i then apply
some non-linear transformation and
activation and so on
at the end i will get the same output
because the aggregation
of yellow and blue is the same
as the aggregation of two yellows and
two blues
even though i encode them in with
different feature vectors
so yellow and blue nodes are definitely
distinguishable because
you know one has the first element set
to on and the other one has the second
element set to one so you see how
mean pulling can basically aggregate
multisets that have the same proportion
of nodes of one type of feature versus
the other type of feature
um into the same representation
regardless of what is the total number
of nodes or what is the total size
of the underlying multiset so this is
the issue
with mean pulling this is a failure case
of min pulling
because it won't be able to distinguish
a multi-set
of size 2 versus size 4 if the
proportion of features
is the same in both
now let's look at a
graph sage max pooling
variant of it so we in the graph stage
we apply
a multi-layer perceptron transformation
and then take a
element-wise maximum pulling um
and what we learn here is that maximum
pooling
function cannot distinguish different
multi sets
with the same set of distinct colors
right so what does what does this mean
is that all these different multi sets
will be aggregated
into the same representation why is that
the case
is because as long as multisets have the
same
set of distinct colors then the whatever
is the maximum
right maximum will be one of the colors
that maximum is the same
regardless of how many different nodes
uh and what are the proportions of
colors in the
um in the multiset so to give you an
example
imagine i have these three different
multisets
i uh i encode these colors using some
encoding
then i apply some non-linear
transformation like an
mlp to it because this is what graph
sage does and let's assume without loss
of generality
that basically now you know these colors
get transformed to some new colors and
we encode these colors with one hot
encoding right so
everything is distinguishable at this
level
but the problem is that now if you take
element twice meaning
coordinate twice maximum in all these
different cases
you get the same aggregation you get the
same maximum value you get
one and one so this means that
regardless whether the node has two
children
four children or 3 children and whatever
is the ratio between
blue and yellow in all cases the maximum
pulling
will give me the same representation so
it means that
all this information here gets lost and
all these
different multisets get mapped to the
same representation
so clearly maximum pulling
is not an injective operator because it
maps different
inputs into the same output
and that's the problem we get these
collisions and information
gets lost and that decreases the
expressive power
of the graph neural network so
let's summarize what we have learned so
far
we have analyzed the expressive power of
graph neural networks
and the main takeaways are the following
the expressive power of a graph neural
network can be characterized
by the expressive power of its
neighborhood aggregation function
right so the message aggregation
function neighborhood aggregation
is a function over multisets basically
sets with repeating elements
um and gcn and graph sage aggregation
functions
fail to distinguish some of the basic
multisets
meaning these two aggregation functions
mean and maximum
are not injective which means different
inputs get
mapped into the same output and this way
the information gets lost
therefore gcn and graph sage are not
maximally powerful graph neural networks
they are not maximally
expressive graph neural networks
so let's now move on and say
can we design the most expressive graph
neural network
right so our goal will be to design
maximally powerful uh graph neural
network
uh among all possible message passing
graph neural networks
and this will the way we are going to do
this
is to to design an injective
neighborhood aggregation function so
basically
a neighborhood aggregation function that
will never lose information
when it aggregates from the children to
create a message
for the parent so the property will be
in injectivity of the aggregation
function
right so the goal is to design a neural
network that can model this
injective multiset function because
that's the aggregation operator
so here is a very useful
theorem the theorem says that any
injective
multiset function can be expressed
in the following way so it can be
so if i have a set of elements right i
have my multiset function
s multiset that has a set of elements
then the way i can write an injective
function over a multiset is i can write
it as a
i apply my function f to every element
of the multiset
i sum up this uh
this uh outputs of f and then i
apply another uh nonlinear function
okay so the point is that if i want to
have an in
injective set over um over a multiset
then i can realize this injective
function by having two functions f
and phi where f i apply to every element
of the multiset
i sum up the outputs of f and then i
apply another
function another transformation uh phi
to it
and uh this means that uh this is how
um a multiset function can be expressed
uh and it will still be uh injective
so the way you can think of the proof
what is the intuition
the intuition is that our f can
produce kind of one hot encodings of
colors right so f
is injective for different node it
produces
a different output um and these outputs
need to be different enough
so that when you sum them up you don't
lose any information so in some sense
if if f takes colors and produces their
one hot encodings
this means that then you can basically
by summing up you are counting
how many elements of each color you have
and this way you don't lose any
information right you say aha
i have one yellow node and i have two
blue notes
and that is kind of the way you can
think of f right f takes the colors
and and kind of encodes them as one hot
so that when you sum them up you
basically count how many different
colors you have of course
f needs to be a function that does that
does this if
f does not do this for you um this won't
uh this won't work so f has to be a very
special
uh function um and then
it will work out
so now the question is what kind of
function f and phi can i use how do i
define them
and we are going to use to use them to
basically define them with a neural
network we are going to define them
using a multi-layer perceptron and why
would we want to define it just using a
perceptron
the reason is that there is something
called
a universal approximation theorem
and it goes as follows so uh a one
a hidden layer maxim uh multiple uh
layer perceptron with sufficiently large
hidden layer dimensionality and
appropriate non-linearity
can approximate any continuous function
to an
arbitrary accuracy right so what is this
saying
it says that i have this unknown special
functions
phi and f that i need to define
so that i can so that i can write my
injective function in terms of
f and phi but f and phi are not known
ahead of time
so but so i'm going to represent
f and phi with neural networks and then
because multi-layer perceptron is able
to learn
any function to arbitrary accuracy
this basically means i can use data to
learn
f and phi that have the property to
to to create these types of injective
mappings
so basically this means that
we have a right to a neural network that
can model
any injective function right if i take a
multiset
with elements x then if i apply a
multi-layer perceptron to it
sum it up and apply another multi-layer
perceptron
then multi-layer perceptron can
approximate
any function so it can approximate my
function f
and phi as well so this means now i have
a neural network
that can do this injective multiset
mapping and you know in theory
this embedding dimensionality the
dimensionality of the mlp
could be very large but in practice it
turns out that you know something
between 100 and 500
is good enough and gives you a good
performance
so what magic has just happened is that
we said
any injected multiset function can be
written as a
um as a uh as a with two functions
f and phi f is first applied to every
element of the multiset summed up and
that that
is passed through the function phi and
this way
the the injectivity uh is preserved
and because of the universal
approximation theorem
we can model f and phi with a
multi-layer perceptron
and now we have an injective aggregation
function
because mlp can learn any possible
and uh and the other mlp also can learn
any function meaning
it can learn the function uh f as well
so um what is now the most expressive
graph neural network there is
the most expressive graph neural network
there is is called
graph isomorphism neural network
or gene for short and the
way its aggregation function looks like
it says let's take messages from the
children
let's transform them with a multi-layer
perceptron
let's sum them up and apply another
multi-layer perceptron and you know
given everything i explained this is a
injective multi-set aggregation function
so it means
it has no failure cases it doesn't have
any collisions
and this is the most expressive graph
neural network
in the class of this message passing
graph neural networks
so it is super cool that we were
basically able
to define the most powerful graph neural
network
um out of an entire class
of graph neural networks and we now
theoretically understand
that it is really all about the
aggregation function
and that the summation aggregation
function
is better than the average is better
than the maximum
so um let me summarize a bit right
we have this right neighborhood
aggregation
function of gene um and we see that
basically the aggregation is a summation
we take messages we transform them
through an mlp
and then sum them up and that has the
injective property
which means it will be able to capture
the structure of the entire computation
graph
now that we have seen what gene is
we are going to describe the full model
of the graphimorphism network
and we are actually going to relate it
back to the uh weis filer layman graph
kernel the wl
graph kernel that we talked about i
think in lecture number two
and what we are going to provide is this
very interesting perspective
where we are going to see that gene is a
neural network version
of the wl kernel so um
let me explain this in more detail
so what is wl graph kernel right it is
also called
a color refinement algorithm where
basically we are given a graph g
and a set of nodes v we assign initial
color
uh c to each node v
let's say we the colors are based on
degree of the node
and then we are iteratively aggregating
hashing
colors of neighbors to create a new
color for the node right so we take the
at uh if you wanna create the color at
level k
plus one for a given node we take the
colors of the nodes
uh u that are its neighbors from the
previous iteration
we take a color of node v
from the previous iteration somehow hash
this together
into a new color right and hash hash
function
the idea is that it maps different
inputs to different
outputs so hash functions are as
injective as possible
and the idea is that after k steps of
this color refinement
the color of every node will summarize
the k-hop
neighborhood structure around the given
node
so let me give you an example imagine i
have two different graphs
here they are they are different they
are
non-isomorphic so the way we do this is
uh let's say we first
simply initialize all the colors to
value one
and then we aggregate right so the for
example this node has color one
and then has three neighbors each one of
color one so this will be now
1 comma 1 1 1 and then you know every
node does the same
now we are going to hash
this descriptions these colors into new
colors
and let's assume that our hash function
is injective meaning it has no
collisions then this would be a new set
of
node colors now and for example in this
case
this node and that node have the same
color because their descriptions
are the same right they have color one
and they have three neighbors each with
color ones so
this particular input got mapped to a
new color
number four and now i can repeat this
process one more time and so on
what you should notice is that at every
iteration of this wl kernel
what is happening is we are taking the
colors
from the neighbors and putting them
together together with our own color
so if you go back and look here this is
very similar
to the graph neural network where we
take messages from the neighbors
combine it with the v's own message
somehow transform
all this into a new and and transform
this and call this that this is the
message
for node v at the next level so this is
essentially
like a hard coded graph neural network
right we take
colors from neighbors aggregate them
take our own color aggregate it and then
call this to be the embedding of the
node v at the next
layer or at the next level
so the point is that as the more
iterations we do this
the farther out information uh is
captured at a given node right the
further out kind of the network
neighborhood gets
more and more hops get added to it um
and the idea with this color refinement
is that
the if you are doing let's say
isomorphism testing
then um the process continues until the
stable coloring is reached
and two graphs are considered isomorphic
if they have the same set of colors
in our case the colors in these two
graphs are different
the distribution of them the number of
them is different which means these two
graphs are not isomorphic
and you if you look at them you really
see that
they are not isomorphic so now how does
this relate
to the gene model right gene uses neural
network
to model this injective hash function
right the way we can
write out gene is we can say it's some
aggregation
over the the embeddings messages from
the children
uh from the neighbors of node v plus
the color the message of the node v from
the previous
uh step so the way we
write this in terms of um
gene operator is to say aha we are
taking the messages
from the children we aggregate we
transform them using an mlp this is our
function f
and we sum them up um and then we
uh also add one plus epsilon where
epsilon is some small
uh learnable scalar our own message
transformed by f and then add the two
together
and pass through another function phi
and this is exactly now a um
an injective operator that basically in
an injective way maps the
neighborhood information plus the um
plus plus the node's own information
into a
unique embedding into a unique
representation
so um if assume that in
input features c is represented let's
say as one hot
encoding then basically just direct
summation
is injective right so if i say how do i
have an injective function over a multi
set where elements of a multiset are
encoded with one hot
then basically all i have to do is
sum up these vectors and i'll get a
unique representation because every
coordinate will count
how many nodes of a given color there
are
now if these colors are not presented so
nicely
you need to transform them with the
function f so that it kind of
approximates this intuitive one hot
encoding
right so this means that a gene
aggregation gene type of convolution
is composed of two m uh two
mlps one uh operated on the colors of
neighbors
one um and then the aggregation is a
summation
uh plus some uh final mlp that again
kind of provides the next level
one hot encoding so that when we again
sum up
information from the children at the
next level no information
uh gets lost so you can think of this
f's and uh
f's and phi as some kind of
transformation transfer
transformations that kind of soft link
do
uh one hot uh encoding
so let's now summarize and provide the
entire
gene model uh gene uh node embedding
update goes as follows right given a
graph with a set of nodes v
we assign a scalar uh vector to each
node v
and then iteratively up uh apply this uh
gene con operator that basically takes
the information from the neighbors
takes its own information applies these
functions
f and phi that are modeled by mlps and
produces the next level embedding and if
you look at this
this is now written exactly the same way
as the wl
right rather than hash here we write out
this gene con
so this means that basically after k
steps of gene iteration
c to c k the the structure of the k-hop
neighborhood
around a given node v
so to bring the two together this means
that gene can be
understood as a differentiable neural
network version
of wl graph kernel right where in
wl we use node colors
and let's say we can encode them as one
hot and we use this
abstract deterministic hash function
while in gene we use node embeddings
which are
low dimensional vectors and we use this
gene convolution
with these two mlps the mlp fee and
mlp f that aggregate
information you know what are the
advantages of gene over the wl
is that no node embeddings are low
dimensional
uh hence they can capture the
fine-grained similarity
of different nodes and that parameters
of the update function can be learned
from the downstream task so we are going
to actually be able to learn
functions f and phi that
ensure injectivity
so you know because the relationship
between
gene and wl kernel their exactly
expressive power is exactly the same so
this now means that
if two graphs can be distinguished by
gene they can be
also distinguished by wl and vice versa
so it means that
graph neural networks are at most
as powerful or as expressive as the wl
kernel or wl graph isomorphism test
and this is great because now we have
the upper bound
we know that gene attains this upper
bound
and we also know that wl kernel both
theoretically and empirically has shown
to distinguish many or most of the real
world graphs
right so this means that jin is the
powerful enough
to distinguish most uh real-world
graphs which is great which is great
news
so let me summarize uh we design
a neural network that can model
injective multiset function
by basically saying that any injecting
multiset function can be
written as a uh application of a
function
f to the elements of the multiset plus a
summation
um in our case we use a neural network
for negative neighborhood aggregation
function uh and
rely on the universal approximation
theorem
to basically say that mlp is able to
learn any function
so this means that gene is able to
capture the neighborhoods in an
injective way which means it is the most
powerful or most expressive graph neural
network there is
um and the key is to use element-wise
summation pooling instead of min or max
pulling so it means that some pooling
is more expressive than min or max
pooling
we also saw that the gene is closely
related to the wl kernel
and that both gene and wl kernel can
distinguish
most of the real world graph structures
to summarize the the the important point
of the lecture
is that if you say about mean and max
pooling for example mean and max pulling
are not able to distinguish these types
of neighborhood structures where you
have two or three neighbors all the same
features
here is where maximum pulling fails
because the number of distinct
kind of the distinct colors are the same
so whatever is the maximum
is the same in both cases and this is
again the case where both mean and max
pulling fail because we have
green and red and they are in the same
proportion
so if you rank uh different pooling
operators by
by discriminative power some pulling is
the best
is most expressive is more expressive
than mean pulling
is more expressive than maximum pulling
so in general some pulling is the most
expressive
to use in graph neural networks
and last thing i want to mention is that
you can further improve the expressive
power of graph neural networks
so the important characteristic of what
we talked today
was that node features are
indistinguishable meaning that all nodes
have the same node feature information
so by adding rich features
nodes may become distinguishable the
other
important thing that we talked about
today is that because
graph neural networks only aggregate
features and they use no reference point
in
in the network nodes that have the same
computation graph structure will are
indistinguishable
and what we are going to talk about uh
later in the
course is actually how do we improve the
expressive power
of graph neural networks um to be more
expressive than
gene and to be more expressive that than
wl and of course in those cases it will
actually require
more than just message passing it will
require more advanced operations
and we are going to talk about those in
the future